brasil superó los 7 millones de casos
confirmados de copy 19 y se mantiene
como uno de los países más golpeados por
el coronavirus al acercarse también a
los 184 mil fallecidos cifras
preocupantes que coincidieron con la
presentación del plan de vacunación de
jair bolsonaro un plan ambicioso que
pretende vacunar a todos los brasileños
en poco más de un año pero que todavía
no tiene fecha y nyc
tenemos una agencia nacional sanitaria
que siempre ha sido un referente para
todos nosotros y sigue teniendo un papel
fundamental en la decisión de que la
vacuna se debe entregar de forma
gratuita y voluntaria a todos los
brasileños forma gratuita y voluntad
para todos los brasileros a pesar de que
brasil tiene cerca de 200 millones de
dosis aseguradas los retrasos en la
vacunación están provocando auténticas
disputas políticas
elpresidente bolsonaro ha confiado casi
únicamente en las dosis de astrazéneca y
la universidad de oxford pero el
gobernador de sao paulo ha apostado por
la china de sinovac asegurando que podrá
empezar a vacunar en enero
no en marzo como algunos creen que
empezará en el resto del país la
compañía china ya envió un segundo
cargamento a este estado pero todavía no
existe ninguna autorización es esta
situación ya está generando inmigración
entre parte de la población de sobras y
brasil empieza a actuar ahora lo que no
está pasando entonces puede que tengamos
esperanza pero ahora es muy complicado
estamos muy atrasados en las
negociaciones de vacunas otros países ya
han comenzado las vacunaciones por lo
que es muy complicado en total brasil
espera adquirir 260 millones de dosis de
astrazéneca que se sumarán a los 40
millones de kóvacs a la espera de cerrar
acuerdos con más compañías